foreign
[Music]
leader is worthless I will create a new
one gentlemen I give you the double
spiral of life itself I propose to
construct our new leader out of DNA
molecules
you know out of all the cold opens we've
ever done that might be my personal
favorite the fact that we were able to
work in the creation as you all know
that was obviously the creation of
serpentor 1985 G.I Joe cartoon I believe
it was called rise serpentor rise you
can watch the full thing on YouTube they
create an evil leader so evil well it
doesn't really work out for them but you
get it they had had it with Cobra
Commander he was the previous leader
they worked on serpenter that one didn't
work out either and I thought that that
was really just sort of a perfect
metaphor in cartoon form for everything
happening uh with this Matt Gates Uh
Kevin McCarthy Fiasco and uh oh yeah
it's October 4th 2023 this is the Reuben
report I'm Dave Rubin we're live
streaming on Rumble locals we're on
Spotify and anywhere you get your audio
podcasts and as always we've got a post
game show at reubenreport.locals.com uh
when we were creating that little
City that we just did right there uh
Phoenix admitted something he said Dave
I thought that was the Transformers
which is so embarrassing I I I'm docking
you pay actually you're not being paid
for today's work I normally don't do
that sort of thing this isn't just you
this isn't just you don't get guacamole
this is you are actually not being paid
for today's work I'm sorry there were no
robots Transformers are robots
good night everybody anyway uh look this
this Fiasco in the house has burst forth
and and in some respects this is just
sort of a perfect example of the
dysfunction in Washington I am going to
try very hard today to honestly assess
the case that Matt Gates is making to
take McCarthy out as Speaker I'm going
to try to honestly assess the case that
McCarthy was making for himself I'm
going to try to show you the weak points
on both the positives on both and and
hopefully you'll be able to uh make an
assessment for yourself but the house
is upside down the house is in an uproar
and uh that may not bode well for
America because we got a whole bunch of
problems as is we got a border problem
we got a Ukraine problem we got a
spending problem and a bunch more but I
thought how can I frame this show
without just diving into like just here
we go
this is what he said this is what he
said let's duke it out well I thought
truth is there anyone that occasionally
tells some truth that might be able to
help us with some of this and then I saw
a clip of my buddy Jordan Peterson who
was on Piers Morgan last night talking
about truth as he often does and the
importance of saying what is true and I
thought we could start with a dose of
that but before we get to that let me
talk to you guys about TWC help guys I
want to introduce you to the wellness
company and specifically their medical
emergency kit awake doctors like Dr
Peter McCullough started the wellness
company to build a parallel Health Care
system and bring about a change in a
corrupt and failing system part of that
change is to help you take control of
your health and supporting you through
whatever the next thing is that gets
thrown our way most people don't trust
health care right now in fact over 40
percent of Americans say that they would
avoid a doctor or a hospital unless it
was a catastrophic situation that's
where the wellness company's medical
emergency kit comes in eight potentially
life-saving medications for you to keep
on hand in times of need natural
disasters supplies change shortages
medical emergencies Etc you can rest
easy knowing that you have emergency
antibiotics antivirals and
antiparasitics to help keep you and your
family safe the kit includes a
comprehensive guidebook so you never
have to guess how much to take or when
to take it and if you're like me you
want to know your family is prepared for
the unexpected go to
twc.health Reuben use code Reuben to
save 15 at checkout that's twchealth dot
sorry that's TWC DOT health slash Reuben
code Reuben for 15 off and now back to
me okay so let's just start the show
with some straight up truth no political
pandering no partisan bickering nothing
else this is Jordan Peterson last night
on Piers Morgan's show talking about the
importance of Truth
and you said something really
interesting to me uh how do you have the
adventure of your life you ask the
people there including many students and
your answer was tell the truth and then
it's so bloody interesting and engaging
and exciting that it justifies the
misery of your existence what can I tell
you there are great books read them
ignore your professors I mean I did love
that because actually there is a real
power isn't there to the truth
particularly in this era I think where
there's so much untruth and
disinformation flying around actually
being true to yourself
is probably the most powerful thing you
can you can be I think the adventurous
element of the truth is associated with
the following idea
I mean I could come on this interview
let's say and I could have been thinking
this morning well what in the world do I
want to accomplish if I get to talk to
Pierce Morgan I'm going to talk to
several million people how can I grow my
brand how can I use this opportunity to
ensure that people feel better about me
or admire me more or something
hypothetically self-serving okay but
it's not self-serving exactly it's it
would serve a very narrow part of myself
it would assert it would serve the
narcissistic self-aggrandizing whim
oriented hedonistic element of myself
and maybe I would confuse that with
myself but that would be foolish
and then maybe I would get what I aimed
at and I'd have a impressive
conversation with Pierce Morgan and that
would re down temporary to my glory and
I would walk away satisfied but the
problem with that is it's a stupid goal
and if I attained it that would just
make me successful at being a being
foolish and narcissistic and the
consequence of doing that repeatedly
would be that I would become more and
more foolish and narcissistic and
there's no success in that even if I got
rich doing that I'd be rich and pathetic
and that's not helpful
just the best he's just the best in
essence what he is saying there is there
is no point bsing you cannot get around
it one way or another you can use
everything and you I promise you you
will see how I'm linking this to
everything going on politically today
you can use every moment to just promote
yourself you can use every moment to
make people look at you or look at this
shiny thing or whatever but you simply
cannot escape the truth and I want to
show you one more clip of Jordan just a
few moments after that that perfectly
relates to what I'll be doing today and
what I've really been trying to do more
than ever on this show I think I was
always doing it maybe subconsciously or
subtly but I'm trying to do it more than
ever now because peers is right we do
live now in a time of Greater
misinformation and disinformation
unfortunately it's just not the
misinformation and disinformation that
the mainstream media tells you they've
just got the whole freaking thing
backwards but the important thing is
that for me for someone that fits here
and you give me a little bit of your
time every day and I can truly consider
that an honor if I don't tell you what I
think honestly about the whole thing if
I think oh you know 50 of my audience
thinks this I better cater to them 70
think this about this other thing I
better cater to them there will be
nothing left here but an empty suit and
that is completely antithetical with to
the adventure of life so one more from
Jordan
alternatively I could come on here and I
could just try to say what I believe to
be the case and then that would be me
and it would be the truth and then I
would be aligned with reality which
seems like a good idea you know because
if it's you against reality like good
luck to you but there's more to it
Pierce because
see if I want to come on to your program
saying just say what I think I have to
throw caution to the wind I can't be
calculating the outcome I can't be like
what would you say referring to an
opinion poll and telling people what
they want to hear I just have to lay it
on the line and to do that I have to let
go of the outcome but the cool thing
here's the cool thing if you let go of
the outcome
you don't know what's going to happen
and then that's so interesting really
that it's almost unbearable and that is
definitely something so interesting that
it's almost unbearable that's an
adventure and then you get to have an
adventure and then you think wow well
this is so interesting maybe it's worth
sticking around for and trudging through
the misery just to see how it ends and I
do believe that you I do believe you
capture that in a relationship with the
truth yes I truly believe that I agree
mystically even is it the truth good
isn't hearing a guy talk about the truth
truthfully good and he's literally in
this case talking to he's talking to all
of us in our own life how we can relate
to the truth what's that that line he
says wouldn't it be good in essence to
be aligned with reality think how much
of the machine and the media and our
politics and all the people who want to
distract you with everything are keeping
you disaligned with reality who don't
want you to think straight when it comes
to literally what you're putting in your
own body or whether you can go to work
or all of these other things but but the
truth is incontrovertible you cannot you
cannot deny it and then if you go for it
for the right reasons
the adventure the freak in it you don't
know what's gonna happen as opposed to
as I mentioned earlier just like
catering if I just sat here thinking
what do they want me to say and
everything else so that is what I will
continue to do there was one other line
let go of the outcome right like that is
it's just so cool like if you just do
what's right and tell the truth for
truth's sake maybe something will happen
and then actually and then I promise you
it'll get us to all the political part
of where we're going today then maybe
when people are doing all the things
that distract us and doing all of the
things that keep us away from the truth
and confused and divided maybe it won't
work because you'll be on that path you
won't be in that conflict with reality
you'll actually be on the road with
reality and while you're on that road
with reality you should wear Gravity the
fire shoes that was a segue and then
we'll get to the other stuff on the
other side guys I want to talk to you
about something that's been making my
days a whole lot easier gravity to Fire
Shoes these shoes are something else
guys I mean I'm a fan of comfortable
Footwear but these shoes take it to a
whole new level they're more than just
shoes they're basically clouds on your
feet I'm not kidding in a double-blind
study by Olive View UCLA Medical Center
and published in the Journal of American
podiatric Medical Association
participants experienced 85 percent less
knee pain its most powerful shock
absorption system put into a shoe
gravity defyer has this patented Verso
shock technology it's like a mini
trampoline in your shoes whether you're
strolling through the park running
errands or even lounging at home these
shoes have got your back or I should say
they have your feet even better they're
stylish you get both comfort and style
that look good and feel great so here's
the deal this gravity defyer is
exclusive to the Reuben report head on
over to
g-d-e-f-y.com
gdefy.com use promo code reuben20 got
check out and get an extra 20 off your
order this 20 discount is a thank you
gift from Gravity to fire for you being
here with us today why not treat your
feet to some well-rested and deserved
Comfort go to
gdefy.com use promo code reuben20 and
give your feet the love they need trust
me you won't regret it and now back to
me okay so let's dive into the lunacy
but as I am one to do before diving into
the day-to-day minutia you guys know I
like to look at some old clips every now
and again to see what got us here
how did we end up at this moment where
Matt Gates a trump Republican
went after Kevin McCarthy a trump-backed
republican Speaker of the House how did
we get here well you guys may remember
that back in March of this year in March
of 2023 uh we spent a couple days in DC
and I interviewed about 20 Republicans
and it was two or three days after Kevin
McCarthy had just taken over as Speaker
they had reopened up the house and a
bunch more so I want to show you just a
small portion of my interview with Matt
gates from back then this is about a
minute long uh and because Gates was one
of the guys that was really holding out
on McCarthy to get some concessions from
him right he didn't want McCarthy to
just be another swamp creature he wanted
to push him and that was obviously good
it took about 15 votes if I'm not
mistaken to get McCarthy the speakership
which he no longer has as of yesterday
and here is gates at that time
explaining why he challenged McCarthy in
the first place so let's talk about that
leverage for a minute because just about
two hours ago I had Congressman Dan
Crenshaw in year and you guys were
obviously on opposite sides of
everything that went down with with
McCarthy and the leadership but that was
my whole purpose of coming to DC I
wanted to sit down with guys that were
on every every side of every issue so
you basically led the the fight against
McCarthy was that were you planning on
doing that did it just kind of
materialize out of nowhere and then did
it become like a monster unto itself
once once it started well I think there
were a lot of people who took leadership
roles on on different issue sets not
every person required the same
concessions to allow McCarthy to ascend
to the speakership you know the the
margin presented a target of opportunity
for us look like I said this is my
fourth term and I'm tired of the way
this place works I think it's deeply
corrupt I think the lobbyists were on
the show most of the times I think
people are more interested in servicing
their Pac fundraiser than they are the
needs of their constituents and it's a
grift game and the way that what
facilitates that grift game is an entire
sophisticated structure that ensures
that no one's really responsible for the
legislating right if we had to take
individual votes on individual
departments and authorizations
and bills and spending then we would
probably be be held to account to a
greater degree by the people in this
country but instead what you get is
every year or so some multi-thousand
page bill that you get a day day and a
half to read and the whole deal is
thumbs up or thumbs down on the whole
thing and then you're left with the
decision of you know voting for a bunch
of crap you don't agree with or leaving
out the widows and the orphans and the
veterans and the military and things
that every American would care about and
we had to force upon the system a better
way to deal with legislating as an
Enterprise and that had features in
policy features and personnel and
features in procedure and that's what
we're working through okay so that was
Gates about eight months ago and I gotta
say that's all good right he's he's
telling the truth the thing that we now
we can all really see it's something
that by the way we do owe Donald Trump
credit for for pulling that curtain back
and letting us really see how the swamp
operates and that the lobbyists and the
donor class are in charge of so many of
these people and really what Gates was
getting to at the end there is I think
really the heart of it even if you move
move the lobbyists aside and everything
else because I do think that there are
some good people there who who despite
lobbyists actually vote their conscience
every now and again that the bigger
issue is they never get one thing to
vote on do we want to help those people
do we want to cut taxes over here Etc et
cetera it's always these crazy bills
that as Nancy Pelosi used to say we have
to pass before we can read them we know
nobody reads them they have 800 things
that are completely unconnected to each
other and if you don't vote for it then
you're hurting Grandma we're putting
trans studies into Pakistan which Conrad
know you're for that one but it's like
you got it guys like it's just all kind
of crazy so I wanted to show you that
because that frames eight months ago
right after the fight to get McCarthy as
Speaker what Gates wanted out of
McCarthy now I want to show you a video
of the very next day and at the very
next day I was in the Capitol with Kevin
McCarthy we actually had about 200 of
you guys from our locals Community come
and join us at the Capitol it was a
great day we took tours around the
capitol McCarthy showed us around
personally it was really fantastic here
he is talking a little bit about his
strategy related to working with
Republicans getting on the other side of
that fight and how the Democrats operate
within that one of the lines that these
guys hear me say probably five times a
week is you don't have to be a
republican but you cannot be a Democrat
and the reason I frame it that way is
it's obvious they've for the most part
gone off the deep end but there's a
there clearly is some sort of branding
issue or something that I think might be
changing I do believe that that you know
for example the Republicans obviously
didn't get that red wave in the midterm
so people clearly are stepping away from
the Democrats but they're kind of I
don't know these Republicans the other
thing too we should we should look at
why didn't the Red Wave come and we
should be very honest with ourselves
there's a couple different reasons why
and I'll tell you look as leader
I'm fortunate in both terms we've won
but
could could we have one more yeah we
could have this idea that
we're just going to pick whoever and
think we're going to win in November no
the top of the ticket is going to hurt
you below the ticket and this idea that
we're it almost happens that we're
better at attacking other Republicans
than standing up for the policies we
believe in well that gets us nowhere
and the other thing too is if you want
to be in the majority and this is what
Reagan said if you agree with us 80 of
the time you're there
somebody who wins in Texas is going to
be different than someone in winds in
California and if you want to sit back
and where did we win the majority well
five new seats in New York we won in
California we want in Oregon we won in
Arizona places that other Republicans
lost
okay so it's interesting you can really
sort of see the the juxtaposition of
their two positions there McCarthy where
it's very much we must hack away at this
system the system is corrupt like he's
going all in on that thing that's that's
one way of looking at it and then you've
got McCarthy who's like there's sort of
a system in place we can kind of work
within that system and you have to
accept that you're going to have even
Republicans from different places a
California Republican for example might
have very different positions than a
Texas Republican but that we should be
working together for this he went on a
little bit to explain how the
Republicans don't really do that while
the Democrats always do and that really
explains what's going on right now
because it was eight Republicans
yesterday who voted to oust McCarthy
along with every single Democrat so one
more from that interview sometimes it's
very important to get the right person
through the primary and you shouldn't
just say okay well this person is the
most conservative well who's the most
conservative who can win in November
that's another thing we have to think
because you've got to have the gavel to
govern the uniqueness like we have a
five-seat majority
they don't hand the gavels out in small
medium and large we get the same size
gavel so and and this is a place as
Republicans should wake up so I look
look back at the vote saying where could
we have done better
top of the ticket hurt today we have 222
members you know what our popular vote
was we want to buy three points two
points better than the time before seven
points better than we did two years
prior so what it means is it's more
competitive we've had redistricting so
it's not that you're going to have these
big majorities that you think things are
just going to happen and
people look through different points
right I mean think for a moment how many
are from Pennsylvania
the one thing I learned is Democrats
will vote for whoever as long as they're
a Democrat
you know
but I will tell you where is John
fetterman where is he
I don't know
but I'm just you know all due respect I
mean
it's just very difficult but Republicans
and and this is where I say we've got to
be honest with ourselves and we've got
to do it before you get the election
if we have a poor candidate rightfully
so we won't we won't all walk and
lockstep and vote for that person
and is that prescient or what pressure
it or prescient depression it's
prescient right is that prescient or
what might be Precious too I just don't
know what that means I made it up
um right he's basically saying if we
don't have a guy that we like we're
going to vote him out and Republicans
will break and do that now he I think
perhaps he didn't think that might
happen to him but that's exactly what
happened these eight Republicans led by
Matt Gates decided to side with all of
the Democrats and he also makes the
point there McCarthy right he makes the
point Democrats always freaking do stuff
in lockstep and that's the odd position
we're at at this very moment you've got
eight Republicans going with all the
Democrats but does that not strike you
even though I have no doubt that most of
you watching this right now are kind of
into the idea that McCarthy is out you
probably if you've been watching this
show in my interviews with him and I've
had multiple you probably don't think
he's evil I certainly don't think he's
evil I think he looked at a system and
was like where where can I make changes
on the margins I can't blow the whole
freaking thing up the the emotional part
of most of us is like screw DC screw the
swap it's more in the gates line of just
like blow everything up that's a just
sort of philosophical do you believe in
burn it all down or do you believe in
fixing things where you can it's a
philosophical difference it's a tactical
difference and I think all of us and and
the guys that we're talking about they
just have to decide what what road is
better for them which can accomplish
more clearly I think we get the sense
that Gates is more on the burn it down
thing and McCarthy is more on the on the
margin side so now let's Flash Forward
to what's happened over the last day or
two uh here is Matt Gates uh filing the
motion to vacate McCarthy for what
persons do the does the gentleman from
Florida now seek recognition Mr Speaker
pursuant to Clause 2 A1 of rule nine I
Rise to give notice of my intent to
raise a question of the Privileges of
the house
the gentleman will state the form of his
resolution
declaring the office of Speaker of the
House of Representatives to be vacant
resolved that the office of Speaker of
the House of Representatives is hereby
declared to be vacant
under rule nine a resolution offered
from the floor by a member other than
the majority leader or the minority
leader as a question of the Privileges
of the house has immediate precedence
only at a time designated by the chair
within two legislative days after the
resolution is properly noticed pending
that designation the form of the
resolution noticed by the gentleman from
Florida will appear in the record at
this point the chair will not at this
point determine whether the resolution
constitutes a question of privilege that
determination will be made at the time
designated for consideration of the
resolution
the chair will now continue with one
minute speak
all right I know we didn't have to show
you all of that but I think it's
sometimes worth just seeing like a
little bit of how the sausage is made
like sort of the stiffness but also the
professionalism and all of that stuff
that that is what the people's house is
all about anyway I think it's fairly
obvious having shown you those videos
from March to where we are as of
literally right this very moment it was
pretty much fairly obvious that we were
going to get to something like this like
having McCarthy out altogether I think
is the surprise but like the fight that
was going to brew between these guys was
was very very obvious all along uh
here's Matt Gates yesterday explaining
why he did what he did I mean the
speaker did not just fail to remediate
the breach of the agreement that you
made with us in January he accelerated
the instances of breach like after I
laid out the breach he went and violated
the 72-hour rule after I laid out the
breach he violated the 100 million uh no
Amendment suspension rule so he he seems
to to be reverting to the very
unfortunate muscle memory of Washington
D.C that has put our nation atop a 33
trillion dollar debt that has led to you
know two trillion dollar annual deficits
in our near future and the rapid Global
detolarization of the economy you look
at the brics system you know Brazil
Russia India China South Africa they're
moving away from the dollar and just in
August they added six new countries
including G20 country economies in the
Western Hemisphere and Gulf monarchies
moreover you've seen you saw U.S news
say that the number one economic trend
of 2023 is D dollarization globally this
worries me you all get all worked up
that there's going to be some
comfortable chaotic moment that I'll
feel pressure from conservatives Or
democrats or whomever I feel the
Judgment of History I feel the weight of
that I worry that when the history books
are written about this country going
down that my name is going to be on the
board of directors here and if this
country is going down and if we're
losing the dollar I'm going down
fighting and I don't care if that means
fighting Republicans Democrats the UNA
party the leadership the Pacs the
lobbyists I've had it I've been here
seven years we don't have a
budget we haven't had one since the mid
90s I am through with it I apologize for
using that word but the only path
forward here is to have single subject
spending bills that can be reviewed
amended considered and I think that is
the responsible way that our
legislatures all over this country
operate for good reason the colorful
language notwithstanding you have to I
think really agree with the heart of
what he is saying we are going into debt
we are printing money we pass bills that
make no sense that no one reads how
about just single line item bills do you
think this is a good policy yes or no do
like let's really know what does funding
Ukraine have to do with funding our
border and trust me those are just like
the two like most obvious examples the
nonsensical things we literally fund
gender studies in Pakistan and all the
rest of the craziness okay you still
you're into that one I don't know why
why he's into that one anyway uh I
personally agree with the heart of all
of that and he's saying I will stand up
for what's right but now I want to show
you because I do think it's important to
show you all sides of an issue I want to
show you the counter to that now
representative Thomas Massey uh I think
is the most Libertarian member of
Congress he's been around for a while uh
and what's interesting about what I'm
about to show you is he he came out
against this move by Gates but think
about the strange bet fellows here Trump
back to McCarthy Gates backs Trump
Gates now took out McCarthy and now
you've got Thomas Massey who back who's
backing DeSantis and DeSantis never
backed McCarthy in the first place like
the the strange bedfellows of this thing
are really wild anyway here is Thomas
Massey who is the most Libertarian
member of Congress anti-war Pro tax Cut
Pro Clean Bill all of the stuff that I
think those of you watching this that we
have common cause in uh explaining why
he's against what Matt Gates just did
because the only still serving co-author
and co-sponsor of the motion to vacate
Speaker Boehner I can tell you this
motion to vacate is a terrible idea is
the only member who's serving here who
took every chance to vote against
Speaker Boehner and to vote against
speaker Ryan I can tell you that this
chamber has run has been run better more
conservatively and more transparently
under Mr McCarthy than any other speaker
that I have served under
as a member of the rules committee what
one of three
one of three conservatives who were
placed there out of trust the speaker
gave us a blocking position by putting
three of us on there to keep an eye on
the rules committee to make sure the
process was fair and even I can tell you
it's been fair and even none of us are
voting against the speaker today okay so
this is super interesting so you've got
a guy who wants less government wants to
cut foreign aid wants to cut taxes
doesn't want to fund Ukraine and all of
those things who was put on the rules
committee if you go back we could have
showed you the clip in that same trip
that we were in DC I interviewed Thomas
Massey and Chip Roy at the same time
those were two of the guys that were
fighting McCarthy the entire time right
because they wanted more clarity and uh
they wanted more transparency when it
came to some of these bills so he put
them on the rules committee and what
Massey basically is saying Messi's not
thrilled with the Ukraine stuff or any
of the rest of it but what he's
basically saying is hey I've been around
Congress for a long time I voted against
Republic like John Boehner who is the
speaker of the house I voted against
Republicans like Paul Ryan who is the
Speaker of the House what he's saying is
in the eight months since we've had
McCarthy this has been better now you
might be Gates and go well I don't care
that it's a little bit better and I
think by the way I think you can be
completely honorable and take both sides
on this position it's just a different
way of looking at the world and looking
at the system do you believe you got to
just blow the whole thing apart which
really is the road Gates is going down
or do you think that over time with sort
of judicious thoughtful movements that
you can reign in government and the rest
of it that's the position that McCarthy
was taking that's the position that
Massey was taking and by the way some of
you will watching this will believe one
some of you will believe the other right
like that that's just okay I think what
makes this sort of scary now
is that eight Republicans have sided
with the Democrats and to me that is a
deal with the devil not because you
cannot be bipartisan right it would be
nice if we had a little more bipartisan
sort of belief in America and sort of
limiting of government and all of those
things we don't have value usually but
the Democrats to McCarthy's earlier
point they stick together the
Republicans Fray and that's how they
took out the Republican leader of the
house now check this out here's McCarthy
yesterday speaking on the floor of the
house and representative ilhan Omar who
is a communist this woman is a far left
lunatic in essence she is a socialist
and a communist she has destroyed
Minnesota she just earlier in this week
is now fighting for 81 000 illegal
immigrants to get IDs in Minnesota
everyone knows what's happened to
Minnesota I mean the Litany of things
that I could tell you about this woman
but check her out licking her lips as
she now knows the Democrats are are in
cahoots with Gates check this out Mr
Speaker I think I've caught the signal
too
the signal is for 33 trillion in debt
facing 2.2 trillion dollar annual
deficits and our fellow Americans may be
watching watching wondering how does
that happen how does the greatest
country in the world have a process
you're gonna eat meat some of that Matt
Gates lunch
she's drooling because she knows they
have now made some kind of deal in
whether Matt Gates likes it or not the
system still exists so congratulations
like you got rid of McCarthy and we will
see it maybe maybe you will be able to
ship these down maybe the Democrats will
see the writing on the wall and be like
boy we have an interesting opportunity
here to not look so psychotic we've got
Matt Gates he's pushing for this you
know line item one vote for one bill
kind of thing maybe we could get on
board that maybe they'll do something
there it would be freaking Incredible or
she's going boy we've basically got this
guy by the balls we just helped him harm
the Republican party and we ain't gonna
give him any more but um
that's tasty
here's uh pramila jayapal she's another
far left I think I think she's basically
a self-avowed socialist uh basically
saying that the Democrats would have
done anything to destroy McCarthy so
sure working with Gates that's pretty
good great Caucus meeting it was
extremely unified we're standing behind
our leader Hakeem Jeffries he is the
person that should be speaker of the
house and there is reason after reason
to uh to just let Republicans deal with
their with their own problems I mean
they can let them wallow in their pigsty
of incompetence and inability to govern
their they are destroying our
institutions
we are not voting in any way that would
help save speaker McCarthy
so you got to remember even if you're
really with Gates on this right at the
moment all of the worst people in the
United States government meaning the far
left Progressive worksters they are
thrilled right now right ilhan Omar is
thrilled right now Maya jayapal is
thrilled right now you know who else is
thrilled I mean one of the worst of the
worst who should be in a cave hiding
along with Anthony fauci for all his
lies over the years Adam Schiff he's
pretty thrilled and he's going to make
sure that McCarthy doesn't make a
comeback you know I don't want to uh
discuss internal caucus but uh I can
tell you my own view which is Kevin
McCarthy is not trustworthy we don't
trust them their own conference doesn't
trust him we've just lurched from crisis
to crisis with him as Speaker
and uh they need to choose someone that
has the ability to govern because it's
not him
and we don't feel
um that it's in the best interest of the
country to have the House of
Representative continue to learn from
crisis to crisis so I hope they can
choose someone that has the capability
of at least
getting us into more productive session
in the house but clearly it's not Kevin
McCarthy you predict that Kevin carthy
will not be the speaker by the end of
today well I don't know where the
Republican votes are but it's certainly
my feeling that democrats should not
enable such an untrustworthy partner as
Kevin McCarthy are you confident that
Democrats will not save Kevin McCarthy
well I know I'm going to vote against
him okay so that was obviously before
the vote happened and then all Democrats
again every single Democrat voted in
lockstep and and just think about this
this deal that now has been cut to get
rid of McCarthy all of the worst people
I just named some of them Adam Schiff
calling McCarthy dishonest and
untrustworthy is now in bed with Gates
so again even if you like what Gates did
you just have to see how the lay of the
land is Shifting right in front of us
the fact that Adam uh the fact that
Schiff and that Adam Schiff is like
empowered right now and that he could
call anyone else dishonest is just so
absolutely incredible but let's show you
the very moment that McCarthy was
removed
on this vote
the yeas are 216.
the Nays are 210. the resolution is
adopted without objection the motion to
reconsider is laid on the table the
office of Speaker of the House of the
United States House of Representatives
is hereby declared vacant
all right that was it McCarthy was out
and I do have to say having gotten to
know him and I've interviewed him not
only in the capital but in my home the
guy has been nothing but a gentleman and
a pro in my experience with him and
again whether you whether you like the
stuff or not he's certainly I'm
certainly not with him on that they kept
funding Ukraine but I also hear Thomas
Massey saying hey this was the best guy
we've got and this is this is a mistake
I can I can acknowledge all of those
things right like two things can be true
at the same time here is Kevin McCarthy
in his first uh press conference after
being removed and like here's just a guy
taking it Like A Champion being a pro
doing the right thing isn't always easy
but it is necessary
I don't regret standing up for choosing
government
over grievance
it is my responsibility it is my job
I do not regret negotiating
our government is designed to find
compromise
I don't regret my efforts to build
coalitions and find Solutions
I was raised to solve problems not
create them
so I may have lost a vote today but as I
walk out of this chamber I feel
fortunate to have served the American
people
I leave the speakership with a sense of
Pride accomplishment and yes optimism
you know isn't it interesting because so
far out of everyone we've talked about
today we haven't shown you anyone that's
really like shredded their integrity and
all of this right like Gates is
absolutely doing what he thinks but is
best I completely agree with that and
again whether you agree with it or
whether I agree there's irrelevant like
he's doing what he thinks is best his
Integrity is intact he's telling you
what he thinks and he's doing it
McCarthy right there he could have
thrown everybody under the bus and done
all sorts of stuff but he's walking from
this thing with his Integrity in fact
the Democrats who I just showed you I
don't think they have much Integrity but
they're doing exactly what they always
do which is be in lockstep with each
other and do everything to destroy the
Republicans everyone's kind of doing
their part so far McCarthy went on to
say he will not run for speaker again
because technically he could run for
speaker again he could try to whip up
the boats and do the whole thing all
over again but he ain't gonna do it
my goals have not changed
my ability to fight is just in a
different form
you need 218. unfortunately four percent
of our conference can join all the
Democrats
and dictate who could be the Republican
speaker in this house
I don't think that rule is good
for the institution
but apparently I'm the only one
I believe I can continue to fight maybe
in a different manner
I will not run for speaker again
I'll have the conference pick somebody
else
so again four percent eight Republicans
worked with the Democrats got rid of
this guy one more time doesn't matter if
you think he was great or think he was
awful you have to think about the
mechanism and ultimately is that good
for America and you might say yes you
might say it's it's worth
Gates's move here to get a simpler
system is worth working with the devil
like cutting a deal with the devil
because that that I think in essence is
what this is you might say that but one
more on Kevin McCarthy here he is just
talking about his uh his future in or
out of Congress
I look forward to your positive
questions
oh I'll look at that
oh you know what I'm sorry we actually
do have two more of him so he's he's
deciding what he wants to do right he's
and I think that's a fair assessment
like his political career in terms of
the upward trajectory is probably over
uh but again he didn't he didn't go down
uh you know just taking everybody out
but he did have some critical words for
the eight guys who uh helped get rid of
him
[Music]
yeah a lot a lot of them I helped get
elected so I probably should have picked
somebody else
I mean that's kind of funny right like
he helps get some of these guys elected
and this is what politics is it's
backdoor deals it's helping get somebody
elected who then turns on you it's going
after somebody who becomes your Ally and
all of those things uh one more
from McCarthy this time uh criticizing
Matt Gates directly not a conservative
look you all know Matt Gates
you know it was personal
it had nothing to do about spending
it had nothing to do about everything he
accused somebody of he was doing
it all was about getting attention from
you
I mean we're getting email fundraisers
from him as he's doing it
join in quickly
that's not governing that's not becoming
of a member of Congress
and regardless of what you think I've
seen the text it was all about his
ethics but that's all right
but look now I would refer you back to
that start Point video we had of Matt
Gates back in March basically saying we
got these concessions at him and if he
doesn't act on these things we'll take
him out while Matt Gates did that
McCarthy's now basically saying
it was never about that because I acted
conservatively again point to the to the
Thomas Massey thing and this guy's in it
for himself there's a lot of rumors
right now that Matt Gates will be
looking to run for governor of Florida
after Rhonda said this regardless of
where desantis's uh presidential
campaign ends up
all right now back to Matt Gates
responding to McCarthy you have to
responding to him to whose benefit
people have called you a narcissist
people say that is to your benefit alone
is it to the benefit of you and to
Donald Trump it's the benefit of this
country that we have a better Speaker of
the House than Kevin McCarthy Kevin
McCarthy couldn't keep his word he made
an agreement in January regarding the
Way Washington would work and he
violated that agreement we are 33
trillion dollars in debt we are facing
2.2 trillion dollar annual deficits we
Face a d dollarization globally that
will crush Americans working-class
Americans Kevin McCarthy is a feature of
the swamp he has risen to Power by
collecting special interest money and
redistributing that money in exchange
for favors we are breaking the fever now
and we should elect a speaker who's
better all right so uh Gates you've got
your moment you got rid of the guy
you've got your moment you've got to
figure out how you're going to deal with
the socialists and the walksters and the
lunatics and the racists and the rest of
the Democrats and I would say good luck
with all of that but now I want to go
back back to sort of the strange bed
fellows here because as I mentioned
McCarthy was a trump guy Gates is a
trump guy they're going after each other
right and I saw this video which was
super interesting this is on Fox Newt
Gingrich now Newt Gingrich who is a a
huge Trump guy Newt Gingrich who was
once speaker of the house and who was a
renegade in his own right contract for
America right all of that he ran for
president as a renegade before Trump was
sort of the one riling up the crowds it
was Newt Gingrich four years before that
but here's Newt Gingrich again a trump
guy against Matt Gates and the eight
reps who did this take a look
96 percent of the Republicans voted for
McCarthy four percent voted against him
from my position as a longtime
Republican activist they're traitors all
eight of them should in fact be
primaried they should all be driven out
of public life what they did was to go
to the other team to cause total chaos
we ought to be focusing on Biden we
ought to be focusing on the economy we
ought to be focusing on the border
instead you're going to get a weaker 10
days of the media focusing on Republican
disarray it's an astonishingly
destructive Behavior by a handful of
egocentric people who think they're
Superior to 96 percent of the conference
and tell us how you really feel Newt
Gingrich but isn't that something again
Gingrich huge Trump guy going after
Gates huge drug guy Trump backing
McCarthy DeSantis did not back McCarthy
Gates into Santa's State here in Far
like to that extent as annoying as a a
lot of this stuff can be like to that
extent it's so interesting the
realignment the fighting here as Brock
just pointed out uh this probably leads
us one way or another to a gap and do
some presidency may God help us all uh
so I just want to give you a little
quick recap Once Again on my feelings on
this I think McCarthy fought as hard as
he could to try to do some good things
he failed in many respects right I am
completely against the Ukraine war I
don't know what the hell we're funding
and we're not funding our border enough
so did was he not great probably but was
he pretty good within the confines of
the system that exists to Thomas
Massey's Point probably is Gates now
doing a deal with the devil that might
that might ultimately do something good
like maybe this will break things in a
way that will get us to something better
on the other side very possibly but
right now do you does it feel like the
Republicans are stronger are the
Democrats stronger right like those are
the two parties we got whether you like
it or not and it feels like the
Democrats are way stronger right the
Republicans are seriously frayed you've
got everybody aiming at everybody it's
that Spider-Man meme of Spider-Man
pointing at Spider-Man and and the
Republican the Republicans are in a lot
of trouble here so
let's go to the other guy that
apparently is in charge of the
Republicans because as I've said
over the course of these 40 minutes or
so nobody really burned their dignity
down in all of this right like even
Gates he's going very hard after
McCarthy but he he and I guess to some
extent he's making it personal but he's
really driving home this point of how
Washington is run and McCarthy is being
honorable as he's walking away right and
Massey is saying hey here's what I think
like nobody really went crazy within all
of that but now I'd like to show you a
post on Truth social from president
Donald Trump why is it that Republicans
are always fighting amongst themselves
why aren't they fighting the radical
left Democrats who are destroying our
country
um Donald Trump have you ever met Donald
Trump uh there's the guy you called Des
Sanctus the sanctimonious there's lion
Ted Cruz whose father you said killed
JFK uh there's bird brain Nikki Haley
who you recently just in the last three
four days sent a bird cage to her hotel
room uh who else what all of them what
milk toast macanoni give me a couple of
others what do you say for Marco Little
Marco give me something else
Chris Christie's just fat
wait was that you or was that Trump yeah
okay
um you know low energy Jeb like all of
these things so think about what Donald
Trump has done to the Republican Party
finding enemies everywhere everyone he
has ever hired who is a republican is an
idiot a a sellout blah blah blah
Trump's opponent the guy he refuses to
say his name DeSantis who he calls the
sanctimonious even though Trump is the
most sanctimonious person in the history
of the world uh he backed he did not
back McCarthy Trump is the one who
backed McCarthy here in the first place
anyway I thought that was worth showing
because what we need out of all of this
maybe the Silver Lining out of this
infighting is not that the Democrats
will will gain strength they're clearly
in the upper hand right now but maybe
maybe sanity could be restored as enough
of us just keep seeing the insanity
right you keep showing us that Insanity
it keeps spreading the lies keep
spreading all of that stuff and maybe a
couple people will be like
you know I've had just about enough of
this
it does not have to be this way I'm
going to start voting for better people
I'm going to start voting for people who
say what they think and do what they say
and all of that I thought Ben Shapiro
said it quite well using only five words
in which week first party to sanity went
wouldn't that be something guys wouldn't
that be something if we could get on the
other side but we can't get on the other
side with the name calling and the lying
and all of this stuff uh Steve days over
at the blaze had a had a long tweet on
this and I think he explained it quite
well sort of what's happening right at
this very moment he said this Foster
clock is happening right now because the
Republican party is ensnared by a trap
of its own making most of the Republican
Party can no longer do out in the open
what it wants to which is betray the
base and pocket the money because of the
emergence of trump and his base
existentially disrupted their Paradigm
as well as expose the fecklessness of
the GOP to an unsustainable level Trump
and the movement surrounding him he
inspired should absolutely get credit
for that however Trump the disrupter
isn't much of an actual leader if you're
going to blow something up better have
something better ready to replace it
Trump didn't he really just expected to
make better deals with the same swamp
rats that were always thus there is no
counter Vision or new breed of leader to
rep to replace the surrender caucus with
because the only standard was will you
slurp Trump you have Trump loyalists
like Gates and Marjory tailored green on
opposing sides with McCarthy
you got McCarthy as speaker at all
because he gladly slurped Trump for
power you have people with good voting
records like Gates aligned with total
rhinos like stephanic and mace when all
they have in common is Trump slurping
everything on the right is about one man
and one man only there is no vision
leadership and without a vision the
people perish which is why Democrats
have outperformed 30 special elections
this year by an average of 11 points
they have a vision albeit a demonic one
but a demonic Vision will defeat a cult
of personality every single time just
like it is defeating us as we speak
that's why Democrats are fine vacating
McCarthy 2 in order to expose these
fissures on the right all the more
divide and conquer is the oldest
strategy known to man that you're United
by a vision while we do Kool-Aid Acid
tests of loyalty not to a vision but to
a singular figure who isn't inclined to
return that loyalty all too often and
given his age won't be relevant all that
much longer anyway so what is the plan
what is the vision there isn't one and
there never was nothing has changed the
cake is still being baked the same it's
just the frosting is zanier than ever
despite all those zany hijinks we're
right back to where we started
Republicans focus on winning the next
election Democrats are out to win the
next Generation uh Steve days if I can
just give you a little golf clap right
there like that is it that absolutely is
it and so what would be the way out it
would not be the show it would not be
the constant disruption and the constant
lies it might be looking for somebody
I won't even name him right now but
could there be a politician out there
who has a track record of Truth and
accomplishment who wins in landslides
who says what he's going to do and goes
ahead and does it and then picks a whole
bunch of other stuff and does that and
fights the media and fights the machine
the entire time would that be a vision
would that be a blueprint for a
successful America could there be some
guy out there
who might be able to do something like
that
perhaps all right guys we're almost to
the end here uh this just broke just a
little bit before we started the show
this is from the citizens Free Press Jim
Jordan is running for speaker of the
house and now to bring this thing full
freaking Circle check this out tweet
from Thomas Massey who was on the
McCarthy side of this thing my first
choice of he will run Jim Jordan and
then a tweet from Matt Gates who is
obviously on the Matt gates side of this
thing my mentor Jim Jordan would be
great all right so maybe just maybe guys
we will get a little Unity out of the
Republicans will it do all of the things
that Matt Gates wants I don't know will
it do all the things that Thomas Massey
wants I don't know but I do know that
I've interviewed Jim Jordan a bunch of
times I know that he gets the issues I
know that he's a deep defender of free
speech in the Constitution and
everything else we shall see what
happens but now I will end the show with
an older Republican who's no longer with
us but who is a wise man who had wit and
character and charm and who actually did
a lot of the things that he set out to
do and did it respectfully and decently
which I think will show you that no
matter what happens here and no matter
how silly the infighting is or the name
calling or the guys who walk out with
their dignity intact or anything else
that these people cannot solve all your
problems right because usually actually
the government creates more problems
than it solves and yes I'm throwing to
Ronald Reagan ain't it one of his
classes
I think you all know that I've always
felt the nine most terrifying words in
the English language are I'm from the
government and I'm here to help
guys I'm from the internet and I'm here
to just tell you what I think and let
the chips fall where they may we got a
post game show right now at
reubenreport.locals.com part one of my
interview with Carl Benjamin AKA Sargon
bacard is up right now on YouTube and
Rumble full things up on locals we leave
you with I believe you can call this
artificially intelligenced manipulation
of the elderly man pretend to be
President Joe Biden see on the other
side
when I woke up to go give me a cold pot
then I thought somebody was barbecuing I
said oh Lord Jesus is a vine
and I'm ready now I didn't grab no shoes
and then Jesus away from my life and
then a small Gap be I got bronchitis
ain't nobody got time for that
[Music]
thank you
Road
s